il est le nouveau président de
l'Argentine et sûrement le plus
extravagant de son histoire cet ancien
chanteur de rock et candidat antiystème
a remporté ce dimanche l'élection
présidentielle contre le progressiste
Sergio Massa dans un second tour sous
haute tension champion de l'outrance et
des coups d'État ravier m 53 ans n'a
qu'une idée en tête destituer la caste
politique parasitaire qui a laissé
l'Argentine s'asphyier dans une dette
record et une inflation équivalente à 12
fois celle de la France cette année
la son programme peut se résumer en deux
mots narchisme soit réduire l'État à
presque zéro et libertarianisme soit
abattre toute entrave à la liberté
individuelle c'est en 2020 en pleine
crise du covid-19 que cette anarco
capitaliste revendiqué fait une entrée
fracassante en politique d'emblé il
casse les
codes cette formule que ravier m
emprunte à un tube de rock des années
2000 devient la mascotte d'un mouvement
politique à l'ascension fulgurante qui
absorbe
ans la droite traditionnelle si le
péronisme un courant politique qui a
dominé l'Argentine ces dernières années
prne la justice sociale et la
souveraineté économique M lui promet
l'opposé découper à la tronçonneuse les
dépenses publiques et abandonner la
monnaie nationale au profit du dollar
américain un programme qui a vite séduit
une partie de la jeunesse et de la
classe industrieuse miné par la crise et
exaspéré par l'insécurité sa force une
maîtrise magistrale de la communication
et des réseaux sociaux cette image
générée par une intelligence
artificielle a par exemple été visionnée
plus de 28 millions de fois sur X le
lion c'est lui et le canard c'est son
allié politique de droite Patricia
bullrich dont les voies les ont mené à
la victoire ce
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dimanche